[Música]
estas son las noticias en france 24 la
convención constituyente de chile tiene
una nueva presidenta la académica maría
elisa quinteros fue elegida con 78 votos
los 155 constituyentes así se termina la
elección que se había postergado esta
madrugada después de 18 horas de debate
kazajistán está en estado de emergencia
además de la declaratoria el presidente
del casino y omar doc ayer pidió ayuda
militar a rusia ya sus cinco aliados ex
soviéticos para enfrentar las
manifestaciones contra el alza del
precio del combustible al menos ocho
policías han muertos y más de 300 están
heridos
y francia rompió su récord de contagios
diarios de kobe de diecinueve por tercer
día consecutivo al reportar más de 332
mil en las últimas 24 horas esto
coincide con la reanudación del debate
en la asamblea nacional que podría hacer
de la vacuna un requisito obligatorio
para entrar a lugares públicos
buenas tardes y bienvenidos a esta nueva
emisión informativa de france 24 yo soy
mar y clara calle y es un gusto volver a
saludarlos y comenzamos hablando de
chile porque marialis a quinteros será
la nueva presidenta de la convención
constituyente que redacta la nueva carta
magna del país austral ella obtuvo 78 de
los 154 votos posibles justo los
necesarios en una apretada elección que
comenzó desde ayer
quinteros hace parte de la asamblea
popular por la dignidad que agrupa a las
principales organizaciones sociales y
territoriales chilenas ella asumirá el
cargo que hasta entonces tenía la
académica mapuche elisa loncón además
llega en un momento clave porque los
próximos seis meses es que se debatirán
y se definirán los artículos de la nueva
constitución chilena
es kazajistán el presidente que asimiló
martock ayer le pidió ayuda militar al
bloque de seguridad o tss liderado por
rusia y conformado por cinco países ex
soviéticos
el mandatario kazajo pretende responder
así a los que han sido los peores
disturbios en la última década y dice
que todo es un plan terrorista que está
detrás además todo el país entró en
estado de emergencia por declaración
presidencial las protestas contra el
aumento del precio del combustible ya
dejan ocho policías muertos y por lo
menos
317 uniformados heridos según el
ministerio del interior el mandatario
aceptó además la renuncia de todo su
gabinete y nombró a un primer ministro
interino juan pupiales nos explica por
qué son las manifestaciones
es la escena de una violencia pocas
veces vista en kazajistán unos
enfrentamientos entre manifestantes y
fuerzas del orden que sacuden al país y
que este miércoles se concentraron en
almaty la ciudad más grande de la nación
a lo largo de la jornada la multitud
llegó a asaltar la alcaldía una
situación que llevó al gobierno a
renunciar y a decretar el estado de
emergencia
los llamados a atacar espacios de las
autoridades civiles o militares son
absolutamente ilegales esto es un crimen
que se persigue con castigo
casaña
tokáyev también anunció que reemplaza al
frente del consejo de seguridad al ex
presidente nursultán nazarbáyev quien
lideró a la nación desde su fundación
hasta 2019 y sigue teniendo una gran
influencia en el país en medio de este
contexto la ong net blogs y agencias de
noticias están denunciando una
interrupción en el servicio de internet
y desde rusia aliado de kazajistán piden
que no haya interferencia extranjera
defendemos una resolución pacífica de
todos los problemas dentro del marco
legal constitucional en lugar de las
protestas en las calles y la violación
de leyes
palabras de moscú que llegan cuando el
kremlin ya tiene un enfrentamiento con
occidente en torno a ucrania otra nación
sobre la que rusia tiene una fuerte
influencia
por tercer día consecutivo francia
rompió su propio récord de contagios
diarios de kobe 19 hoy se confirmará un
poco más de 332 mil una cifra que ayer
estaba en cerca de 272 mil además la
asamblea nacional reanudó el debate
sobre la ley que haría que la vacuna
contra el coronavirus fuera obligatoria
para entrar a lugares públicos el senado
lo debatirá el proyecto el 10 de enero
por su parte del presidente de manuel
majo enfrenta a una ola de críticas por
decir que quería fastidiar a los no
vacunados aunque su gobierno insiste en
que las dosis son la solución y
yo no diría que la vacuna es ineficaz
diría que por suerte la tenemos sabe qué
pasará con 300.000 casos por día tiene
ni idea de lo que pasará con 300.000
casos por día como si no fuéramos uno de
los países más vacunados del mundo si
pueden imaginar que durante la primera
ola estaba en un nivel de infección
mucho menor que el que estamos viendo
hoy las vacunas una vez llegaron a
nuestro país salvaron cientos de miles
de vidas y así continuaremos
en italia la vacuna contra el kobe 19
sera
para los mayores de 50 años así lo
decidió el gobierno en el consejo de
ministros que tuvo hoy esto implica que
quienes deben ir a trabajar primero
tendrán que demostrar que tienen las
dosis contra el coronavirus o que ya se
contagiaron además italia registró hoy
su mayor cifra de casos de coronavirus
confirmados en un día al reportar poco
más de 189.000
josep borrel el alto representante de la
unión europea para asuntos exteriores
visitó la región del donbass disputada
por separatistas pro rusos y ucrania él
es el primer jefe de la diplomacia
europea que va hasta esta zona en
conflicto desde allí dijo que el bloque
de los 27 debe estar en los diálogos que
mantienen rusia y eeuu para reducir las
tensiones militares oxida mente acusa a
moscú de querer invadir a ucrania algo
que el kremlin niega sin embargo los
europeos no hacen parte de la reunión
que habrá en ginebra- el 9 y 10 de enero
entre el kremlin y la casa blanca
borrell aún así reafirmó su postura a
favor de ucrania
reduciremos las tensiones a través del
diálogo para evitar que aumenten para
buscar soluciones pero con una postura
firme y con el fuerte compromiso de que
cualquier agresión militar contra
ucrania tendría consecuencias masivas y
costos severos
cosas estamos coordinando con eeuu la
otan y otros socios afines para trabajar
por la reducción y la implementación
completa de los acuerdos de minsk
en
eeuu y alemania también respaldaron a
kiev el secretario de estado de la casa
blanca- anthony blinken y la ministra
alemana de relaciones exteriores-
anna-lena verbo que se reunieron en
washington con la intención de lograr un
frente unificado sobre rusia afirmaron
que la concentración militar rusa sobre
la frontera con ucrania es un desafío
inmediato y urgente blinken agregó que
es difícil tener avances con moscú si el
kremlin le pone una pistola en la cabeza
a ucrania
tanto alemania como eeuu ven las
acciones de rusia contra ucrania como un
desafío inmediato y urgente a la paz y
la estabilidad en europa
condenamos el aumento de militares rusos
en las fronteras de ucrania así como la
retórica cada vez más dura de moscú
mientras continúa impulsando la falsa
narrativa de que ucrania busca provocar
un conflicto con rusia
otra de las noticias que llegan desde
eeuu es que hoy testificó el nuevo jefe
de la policía del capitolio tom manger
en la investiga por la toma al congreso
el reconoció que el asalto del 6 de
enero del 2021 expuso que hay fallas en
la planificación de defensa y la
dotación del equipo del capitolio por su
parte del presidente joe biden dijo que
donald trump tenía una responsabilidad
singular por provocar el caos el
departamento de justicia asegura que se
encargará de que los perpetradores del
ataque al legislativo en todos los
niveles rindan cuentas ante la justicia
escuchemos lo que precisó el jefe de la
policía sobre el asalto hoy estoy seguro
de que el departamento de policía del
capitolio de eeuu ha logrado un progreso
significativo abordando las deficiencias
que afectaron la respuesta del
departamento el 6 de enero y aunque
queda más trabajo por hacer los hombres
y mujeres de la policía del capitolio
están listos para cumplir con su misión
todos los días
el tenista serbio novak djokovic sigue
en el aeropuerto de melbourne esperando
que lo dejen entrar a australia para el
gran slam aunque desde medianoche
aterrizó las autoridades locales del
estado de victoria dicen que el jugador
solicitó una visa que no permite
extensiones médicas
djokovic que no informó nunca si estaba
pero se había pronunciado en contra de
estas dosis anunció ayer que recibió la
exención por su parte el presidente
serbio aleksandar vucic dijo que el país
apoyaba al número 1 del tenis
y para terminar les hablamos de los
premios grammy que otra vez se
pospusieron por la pandemia los
organizadores decidieron no realizar la
ceremonia el 31 de enero como estaba
previsto pues creen que hay demasiados
riesgos por la variante omicron todavía
no se ha anunciado cuándo será la nueva
fecha el año pasado ocurrió algo similar
cuando los premios musicales se movieron
de enero para mediados de marzo por el
cob y 19
y hasta aquí las noticias sigan con
nosotros
[Música]